welcome to the second part of our top 10
questions for customer engineers let's
jump right into it question number 6
how does Google secure my data we
encrypt at rest and in transit our
infrastructure doesn't rely on any
single technology to make it secure we
design security of our infrastructure in
layers that build upon each other from
the physical security of the data
centers to the security protections in
our hardware and software so the
processes we use for to support
operational security this layered
protection creates strong security as a
foundation for everything we do data
stored on our infrastructure is
automatically encrypted at rest by
default and distributed for availability
and reliability we also support customer
managed encryption keys using cloud kms
and customer supplied encryption keys
communication over the Internet to our
cloud services are encrypted the scale
of our infrastructure allows us to
absorb many denial of service attacks
and we have multiple layers of
protection that further reduce the risk
of any DDoS impact finally our
operations team detects threats and
responds to incidents around-the-clock
security is important and applications
are often business critical to our
customers so they need to be confident
that Google cloud is reliable and
scalable question number seven is Google
ready for the enterprise that is a great
question that every customer should be
asking and we got lots of customers to
answer that one for us you can read what
they have to say about this by going to
cloud I Google comm slash customers
you'll see that folks from Charles
Schwab and the Chicago Department of
Transportation to Johnson & Johnson and
the National Institute on Aging have all
decided that Google cloud is reliable
scalable and secure enough for them
analysts agree with them for example
Forrester just named Google cloud a
leader in their public cloud platform
native security report this all just
goes to show our combination of
world-class infrastructure research and
thought leadership and folks just like
these customer engineers next to me all
add up to making google cloud
the place to run and a private workload
that sure makes us feel better about
running business-critical applications
on GCP but aren't due question eight how
do I control my cloud costs we have many
ways to help you estimate and control
your costs you're always able to use the
pricing calculator to help estimate what
your workload costs might look like once
you're on the cloud once you're up and
running your instances and services can
be labeled to help organize your
resources billing data can be exported
to bigquery
in order to review and analyze what
you're spending in case the default
bills aren't descriptive enough plus you
can set up budgets and alerting from
your cloud console to warn you well
ahead of time before you spend your
budget oh I've dropped my contacts and
we're back let's see where were we
that's right question number nine what
is a managed service and what problems
does it solve well a managed service is
exactly what it says on the box it's a
set of services or products where Google
takes care of the upkeep and maintenance
since its inception Google has put a
strong focus on marrying open source
technologies with fully managed services
well we focus on the maintenance you get
the product that truly stands out
allowing you to refocus your engineers
time for my maintenance centric approach
to a feature focused strategy that
ensures your time and effort are being
spent on the things that will set your
application and company apart from the
rest a good example of this no ops
approach is best shown when we discussed
the concept of flat migrations with
Google cloud we seamlessly migrate your
instance to another machine during
Google's Howard maintenance events so
that you don't suffer any downtime most
of our users don't even notice finally
drumroll please
question number 10 what makes GCP
special well us of course
and in addition Google cloud platform
differs in a variety of ways including
our security model which is an
end-to-end process built over 15 years
of experience keeping our customers safe
on Google Apps like Gmail we offer a
global network our network backbone has
thousands of miles of fiber-optic cable
using advanced Software Defined
Networking and edge caches globally to
deliver fast consistent performance we
also live and breathe big data we
contributed to innovations like
MapReduce big table and Dremel and new
frameworks for data warehousing and
machine learning even batch and
real-time data processing our solutions
are serverless and they let you take
advantage of the years of research that
we've done and we offer compute engine
billing by the second so you don't have
to pay for compute minutes that you
don't use and of course we are
environmentally friendly and our data
centers run on half of the energy of a
typical data center in 2017 we purchase
100% renewable energy to match our
consumption for our global operations
thanks for watching and make sure to
LIKE comment and subscribe below and if
you like to get in contact with us click
on the link in the description
[Music]